poor health has actually become the
normal all around us it's one of those
things where you become blind to it the
predominant messaging around healthy
food has been the food pyramid the food
pyramid should essentially be flipped
upside down we got it so wrong that it
almost has to be intentional when you
really isolate out red meat you cannot
find a relationship with heart disease
or cancer or any of these ill health
effects everyone has to realize they
have the power within themselves to keep
themselves healthy and to not need me as
a heart surgeon all right guys bang bang
I've got Dr ovidia here with me uh I
thought a great place to start a
conversation was uh there's a lot of
people on Twitter they share all kinds
of crazy uh conspiracy theories or or
medical advice or whatever it's usually
not a doctor so uh one you got going for
you you are a doctor uh you've done over
3 000 heart surgeries uh but also what I
find fascinating is you are somebody who
has taken the things you're talking
about the internet and put into practice
in your own life you lost over a hundred
pounds yourself and so there's two
unique aspects you're a doctor you
actually have seen some of this stuff in
practice yourself why talk about it on
the internet like what like what has got
you so excited and so amped up about
kind of sharing this stuff with uh with
the audience that you've built on the
internet
yeah it really comes down to you know I
my purpose as a doctor is to help people
and that should be any way that I could
help them so you know for the first part
of my career the way I help people was
by doing heart surgery and I still
continue to do that but what I've come
to realize through my personal journey
through losing 100 pounds through
addressing how unhealthy I was as a
doctor was that I can help even more
people now by not needing a heart
surgery by educating them teaching them
how to be healthy how they can go down
the same path I went down and you know
that's sort of the higher purpose I
think uh that's the calling now so I
continue to be a heart surgeon I
continue to help people who need that
yep but I would much rather people not
need the heart surgery I'd much rather
they stay off my operating table
ultimately so I've seen you talk about
your successful professionally but you
were unsuccessful from a personal health
standpoint uh let's talk first about the
professional career of a heart surgeon
how long does a heart surgery take and
like what exactly happens because the
patient gets knocked out right uh most
people haven't been in the room like
when you say heart surgery talk us
through kind of at a high level like
what is that process like sure thing so
you know the most common type of heart
surgery we do it's called coronary
artery bypass grafting cabbage as it's
uh known and that is for people who have
developed blockages in the arteries of
their heart and we need to basically
reroute the blood we need to get better
blood flow going so that surgery
typically is going to take anywhere from
about four to six hours from the
patient's standpoint
a lot of that is kind of prepping and
ending you know so my actual time in
there you know when I'm really in there
with my hands in someone's chest is in
the three to four hour range typically
sometimes less sometimes more depending
on what we're doing and when you are
rerouting it uh I'm going to be the
educated idiot here for sure uh when I
think of a blockage in an artery it's
literally something has built up and is
blocking the clean flow of the blood uh
are you simply trying to remove the
blockage so that then they can continue
the same artery or you you almost
building like an artificial artery
around the blockage like how does that
work yeah so what I do is Lay new pipe
essentially you can think of it
um in some situations we can open up the
pipe that's what stents are so one of
the kind of misconceptions you know
everything gets lumped into heart
surgery
but stents are typically put in in
what's called a catheterization lab by a
cardiologist and in situations where
that's not applicable the heart surgeon
then does bypass surgery and this is
really as we said laying new pipe so we
don't typically unblock the blockages
that are there we give a new route for
the blood to go around the blockage got
it and so this is uh what I would
consider the uh kind of defensive
mechanism if you're an unhealthy person
uh and you've like screwed up for a long
time right I'm assuming they get to you
and you're like okay get on the
operating table and I will like cut open
your chest and literally fix the problem
but what I find fascinating is that when
you were talking about being an
unsuccessful healthy person uh you
actually spent a lot of your time being
like never get to me like there's a way
to play offense and as I kind of went
down this Rabbit Hole understanding kind
of your journey and what you had done it
really just comes down to the food you
eat it seems like like that was a huge
piece I didn't really see you talk about
uh a lot of the other kind of more
exotic things it was just like eat in a
different way and that will do a very
big percentage of the work to keep you
off of the operating table is that like
a a fair way to evaluate kind of the
conclusion you've come to there yeah it
really is and it's not only applicable
to you know what I do heart surgery
really when you look at all of our
problems around Health these days most
of them come from us making ourselves
unhealthy
um we have gotten into a situation
um where first of all we've normalized
being on health
um you know some of the statistics are
just truly frightening uh the one that
probably I cite most often is that 88 so
almost nine out of 10 adults in the
United States today are not healthy uh
when we look at you know the definition
what we call metabolic Health five basic
criteria of health and nine out of ten
adults cannot meet that we look at other
statistics like 60 percent of the adults
over 50 years of age in the U.S are not
only on one medication they're on
multiple prescription medications so
poor health has actually become the
normal all around us and it's one of
those things where you become blind to
it we don't even really expect to be
healthy anymore and we spend all of our
efforts all of our energy
trying to manage our illness instead of
trying to remain healthy in the first
place and that's where I think we need
to refocus our efforts you know talking
about doctors talking about the Health
Care system in particular and that's
where each individual everyone has to
realize they have the power within
themselves to keep themselves healthy
and to not need me as a heart surgeon or
not need the Health Care system in
general what's fascinating about what
you're talking about here is there is
one aspect which like I'll put into like
the cultural Wars this is people on
Twitter going nuts when they see uh the
fat mannequin at the store and they're
like oh my God we're normalizing
unhealthy uh kind of Standards there is
what you're specifically talking about
which is more of like the pharmaceutical
uh approach of like
it probably hasn't always been the way
that people lived where hit 50 here's
six pills and like there you go right
obviously some of these pulls didn't
even exist prior now they do and so are
we simply using the Pharmaceuticals as
uh a Band-Aid on other problems uh and
then also there's just like is there a
rise in the worsening of the way people
feel whether that's like depression and
some of the mental health stuff uh is it
just literally their blood pressure's
going up and maybe they're not even
actually taking medicine and so they end
up just having kind of shorter life
Horizon like it feels all of this is the
same thing right it's different ways to
kind of break down the conversation or
frankly argue on the internet but really
what we're getting back at is like
Americans don't live a very healthy
lifestyle in general and I think you're
really highlighting a lot has to do with
the food that we eat
yeah I think that's a great way to think
about it you know we if we start to
think about this sort of uh information
environment around health and we start
to see that so much of this can be
tracked back to the food that we eat
um we see the clear shifts over time
that as more and more processed food
gets introduced into the environment
people become more unhealthy populations
become more unhealthy and yet we in a
for many reasons
won't address the food part of it we say
well we can take care of that with
something else whether it be
Pharmaceuticals whether it be surgeries
um you know the the sort of view of the
Health Care System
um is that okay we're going to deal with
the problem we're going to manage the
problem but we're not really going to
address why the problem occurred in the
first place
when you see the rise in processed foods
what is driving that is that capitalism
is that uh the need and want to have
better preservation uh of food is that
uh some altruistic view of like let's
feed the hungry like what is driving uh
such a rise in processed food yeah it's
interesting
um you know it probably started
um
hunger starvation you know was a problem
historically for much of our existence
as human beings when you go back to the
ancestral record
um it was a struggle to get enough food
so you could say that it probably
started from that sort of altruistic uh
standpoint and obviously as the
population grew and we got into uh you
know we got out of the nomadic life
um it necessitated being able to have
food
available being able to store food and
then you know being able to move food
from place to place
um all of these things became necessary
but at some point and I think this is
fairly recently we reached this sort of
tipping point where now the problem
wasn't starvation anymore food was
abundant food was available
and now we've got the opposite problem
where we're in an excess environment and
our bodies haven't caught up with that
on the evolutionary standpoint
um and you know so I think the original
intent to sort of processed food was
altruistic was Noble we got to save
people you know we got to be able to
keep people alive uh but we've now
clearly reached the problem where the
processed food is problematic is causing
health problems is having the opposite
effects and it's shortening people's
lives but now we're so entrenched in
that way of thinking in that system uh
that you know it's hard to get out of it
like most big institutions you know big
food is an institution and uh it's an
institution that has powerful
effects you know across all aspects of
society and now we've got to figure out
how to undo this problem that we've
created
there's a a rule uh town in North
Carolina my wife and I were driving
through uh at one point and it's kind of
one of these streets where uh there's I
don't know three four five stop lights
but it's a one-way or a a kind of
straight shot that you can look down and
uh for whatever reason I said to her oh
my God look at all the signs and it was
Wendy's McDonald's Bojangles Chick-fil-A
it was just like all of it right yep and
uh it was almost like a shot you would
see on uh on the internet right that
kind of goes by one we were like wow
America is like so stupid
um and as we looked
what I think shocked me was in that
small town I don't know if you could
have an average salary and eat healthy
right because everything that was thrown
in your face was cheap and unhealthy and
so how much of the like obesity epidemic
or or kind of the rise in the unhealthy
American is a socioeconomic and like a a
poverty problem or a um a money problem
versus no people have the money to go
and eat healthy it's just they aren't
educated or they're lazy and they don't
want to do the work to actually do that
yeah so I I do think that both play into
it you know because when you look at you
know why is processed food so
inexpensive
um you start to look at government
incentives around you know the crops
that get subsidized
um versus uh you know why aren't those
subsidies going to the the ranchers who
are raising you know cattle
um so you have to ask why is that food
the inexpensive food I mean the reality
is doesn't need to be that way we could
very easily shift what becomes the
inexpensive food for people and then
there certainly is the
um
educational piece of it and quite
frankly we start to get into the
mis-educational piece of this because
you know the predominant messaging
around healthy food here in the United
States for the past 50 years has been
the food pyramid that you know grains
whole grains are the healthiest thing
you should be eating and uh you know
cereals and wheat and all of this that's
insane it is insane that is literally
insane we have more than enough evidence
at this point to know that that
shouldn't be the case you know the food
pyramid should essentially be flipped
upside down so then you start asking
those questions because it's like okay
not only have we gotten this wrong but
we got it so wrong that it almost has to
be intentional like you know you can't
you can't mess things up this badly
without there being some intentionality
to it okay so this highlights uh
something that I've seen a number of my
friends talk about well which um
put me they put me down a rabbit hole
like oh man now I'm right now I'm really
messed up uh so I've had a bunch of
friends who have gone to Europe over the
last couple of years and they're like I
went to Europe I ate all the bread I ate
tons of pasta I ate all of the gelato
and you know whatever else that they
could eat and they felt like they were
eating disgustingly unhealthy
and they came back and they had lost
weight yep and of course the questions
come like well were they walking more
than normal like all that type of stuff
and uh the people that I've seen talking
about this and kind of been the most
confused by it is like they're like no I
walk a lot at home and I looked at my
you know data or whatever steps are
pretty much the same it has to be the
food and so you're talking about just a
food pyramid where grains are seen as
like the most acceptable uh uh kind of
food group
but actually it seems even the grains in
America are different than maybe the
grains that you would eat in Europe or
elsewhere it's like maybe let's start
there of just like before we flip the
food pyramid like what is the difference
or at least your understanding of the
difference between the types of grains
or pastas or whatever that people are
eating yeah so uh and I've had the same
experience myself you know going to
France and eating the croissants and the
baguettes and all of that and yeah you
know I first of all I didn't feel lousy
like I do when I eat bread here and
second of all I you know didn't gain any
weight and same thing yeah I'm pretty
active here I was pretty active there uh
it's interesting because we go back to
the whole
um what led us to the food pyramid and
what led us to the food pyramid was
basically you know in the 1950s we had
this Rising epidemic of heart disease
here in the United States
um a sitting president had a heart
attack while in office and this set off
the alarm bells and so we started asking
what causes heart disease and there were
two prevailing theories at the time
um the one theory was that it was sugar
essentially processed carbohydrates that
was leading to heart disease and the
other theory was that it was saturated
fat in the diet
and the saturated fat diet the saturated
fat Theory won out and we can get into
all of that but it won out it became the
prevailing theory was it a fair game did
It win on Merit or did It win because
people were lobbying and playing kind of
[ __ ] games yeah in retrospect I
would say that it was not a fair game so
uh one of the prominent scientists who
promoted the theory of saturated fat
causing heart disease Ansel Keys We Now
know
basically made up a lot of his data wow
so the seminal I shouldn't say made up
manipulated is probably a better word so
the seminal study that he put forward
early on was called the six country
study and what he did in that study what
he published in that study was looking
at six countries and looking at their
consumption of saturated fat and looking
at their incidence of heart disease and
it makes a nice straight line looks like
a perfectly linear relationship and so
that got published and then everyone
said okay it's obviously saturated fat
what we now know is that Ansel Keys
actually studied 22 countries and he
hand-picked the six countries that had
this relationship
um and you know this was known in a lot
of ways you know when you go back
through the 1970s and the 1980s for
instance people talk about the French
paradox when it comes to heart disease
because we knew that the French consumed
more saturated fat than just about any
other westernized country you know think
Julia Child think about the butter and
everything and yet they had the lowest
incidence of heart disease of any of the
westernized countries so this was always
thought about well the French must be
you know they must exercise a lot or
they you know whatever it is in their
lifestyle that negates this effect of
saturated fat but the reality is is that
there never was in effect a saturated
fat to start with
and the real problem with the saturated
fat theory of heart disease dietary
saturated fat causing heart disease is
what it then led to because then we got
down this whole pathway of okay we got
to take all the saturated fat of our out
of our food supply and if you're going
to do that that means you have to be
processing the food and you have to be
putting something else in and what got
put in sugar processed carbohydrates and
that you know we in the 80s it became
all about the snack Wells and everything
was labeled low-fat low-fat low fat and
if it's labeled low fat it means it's
been processed it means sugar has been
added to it in some form and here we are
40 50 years later and we can see the
devastating effects that this has had so
I'm not a genius by any means
but you just told me that there was two
theories one was saturated fat one was
processed sugar and
what I see you getting at here is that
the saturated fat theory that was the
prevailing Theory and that's why we went
and made all these changes we actually
decreased saturated fat but we increased
processed sugar and if I can read
between the lines maybe it was the uh
the opposite that it was the processed
sugars that was creating all the heart
disease we actually made the problem
worse rather than better yeah and that's
exactly what we see now you know as I
said here we are 50 years later heart
disease is still the number one killer
in the United States and worldwide so we
haven't solved that problem and even
worse what we see is obesity up diabetes
up all of these other
problems that come along with it because
it turns out that you know processed
food doesn't just cause heart disease
um if it makes you metabolically
unhealthy which it does and we can get
into what exactly that means it's not
only going to increase your risk of
heart disease it's going to increase
your risk of many types of cancer it's
going to increase Alzheimer's disease
it's going to increase many of the
chronic diseases that are now plaguing
our society we can go down the list of
the top 10 causes of death every year in
the United States and seven out of the
Ten of them are directly attributable to
the poor metabolic Health that results
from eating this processed food
so when you look at processed food
people will say tastes great right like
like that that's the no doubt and uh I
always use the the one fact of uh the
McDonald's french fry is like
scientifically engineered to make you
want to eat more of them and when people
start thinking like what do you mean
it's like well uh it doesn't mean that
they literally are in a lab you know
with uh running experiments and all this
stuff although there is uh uh evidence
that suggestions maybe they were doing
that yeah right but what it does mean is
that they are trying to make it taste so
good that every time you're I'm hungry
you think hey I want to go get
McDonald's but they also want to do it
in a way where they can produce it for
next to nothing and there's profit
margins and kind of all this now as you
said they actually are in the lab
testing a lot of this stuff and what I
saw when you were talking about having
lost 100 pounds
was your previous diet was eat what I
want when I want which I think most
Americans are like that's what I do
you still today eat what you want when
you want it's just that you changed what
you eat and so I think the first kind of
big like aha for a lot of people is just
like you don't have to suffer in order
to actually lose weight right you can
eat whatever you want as much as you
want like all the stuff you just have to
eat the right types of food which I
think is a unique message because what
people are used to doing is getting
bombarded with this fad diet or that fad
diet or take this pill or do this thing
or you know the the seven day water fast
or you know whatever it is that's not
what you're saying at all you're just
saying like hey if you just eat healthy
food rather than unhealthy food like
you're probably gonna get much farther
along than you would otherwise yeah
certainly true and this was an aha
moment for me you know so
I wouldn't even really say you know that
I was eating whatever I wanted whenever
I wanted you know I had
um what most people would consider a
healthy diet
um you know I grew up in a household
that we followed the food pyramid
um my older brother is a type 1 diabetic
we had no sugar in the house
um we drank our skim milk on our
Wheaties and our Cheerios and uh you
know I would say we had a healthier diet
than most
um I was also very active you know
that's the other thing that people say
oh well people get fat because they're
not active enough I played Sports year
round I rode my bike everywhere I walked
you know I grew up in a very Suburban
environment and despite this I became
more and more unhealthy and you know
then I got to college and then I got to
medical school and so now I learned all
the nutritional science you know all the
stuff uh and you know one of the
unfortunate things about going through
medical school is we don't cover a lot
about nutrition but what we do cover
um I followed you know and then I tried
all of those miserable things that
people do to lose weight you know I
counted my calories I did the the points
and the shakes and all of that stuff and
like most people I had the experience
that it would work for a little bit of
time I could stick with it I had enough
willpower I'd lose some weight and then
you just can't stick with it anymore and
you end up gaining back the weight and
more
so the big aha moment for me the big
change for me was exactly that I heard a
talk at a medical conference by a
journalist by the name of Gary Tobbs and
uh Gary at the time had just written his
book the case against sugar prior to
that he had written uh good calories bad
calories and why we get fat and Gary
came at this problem as an investigative
journalist he started investigating the
food the diet industry and you know he
went back through a lot of the science
he has a science background as well as
his journalism background and he saw
that it's not about the amount of food
that we eat it's not calories in
calories out as we had all heard our
whole life but the types of food that
you eat have a unique
influence on your metabolism and on how
hungry you are so it turns out when you
eat good food when you eat whole real
food I always explain it as the things
that grow in the ground and the things
that eat the things that grow in the
ground
and when you stick to eating these Foods
your body can tell you you've gotten
enough you're not hungry you don't need
to be hungry all the time and so as you
said I now eat what I want when I want
but what I want is good nutritious whole
real food and when I want it is a lot
less often because I'm not hungry all
the time because I don't have these
processed foods that are hijacking my
Hunger mechanisms so to get back to what
you were saying you know are there
people in the lab sitting there trying
to figure out what makes me what makes
me more hungry what makes you more
hungry yes there are there are food
scientists who have been hired by the
food industry to specifically figure out
how do we get people to buy more food
because ultimately that's the goal of
the food industry they're a business
like any other business and they want
you as hungry as possible they want you
buying their food that has the big
profit margin in it and this is now the
environment we're in if you think about
you know you walk into your standard
Supermarket these days
ninety percent of what's in there is
processed food
um and
it is specifically engineered to make
you more hungry
the unfortunate side effect is that it
also makes us less healthy
um and so we're now in this situation
whereas you know where we're kind of
stuck in this environment where almost
everything around us yes we have lots of
food around us but it's not supporting
our health and it's
keeping us more hungry and making us
more unhealthy when we eat it it's wild
to think that uh the brands and the
companies that we've entrusted with uh
ensuring that we're not hungry are
actually helping to make us more
unhealthy and ultimately kill us right
um and I had a Texas slim uh Texas
cattle rancher uh on uh on the show we
were talking and one of the things he
said is when you go into the grocery
store stay against the walls yeah right
don't go in the middle he's like that's
cartoon land it's just there's bright
colors and they got all the characters
and like the more that you see that
stuff the more they're trying to get you
to buy something and distract you from
the fact that it's probably not nutrient
dense and so when you go to the grocery
store like what do you do how do you go
through the grocery store like what do
you buy for you and your family to eat
on a on a daily or weekly basis
it's the okx the new race car maybe but
actually no okayx is one of the world's
leading crypto trading apps okay
yeah so it's it's mostly that and uh you
know slim and I are friends and and we
talk and um you know we share those
ideas so my trips to the grocery store
um are around the outside of the store
you know you walk in you have your
produce section
um you have your meat section your
Seafood your Dairy and you're out it's a
quick trip
um it really is a lot less stressful one
of the things that I try to explain to
people these days and it they look at me
so strangely it's such a strange concept
that I think a lot less about food these
days I don't spend all my time you know
what am I going to be eating what am I
preparing you know it becomes very easy
to come home
you have something in the fridge or the
freezer you can prepare most of these
Foods pretty simply you know you take a
steak you throw it on the grill four or
five minutes each side you're eating in
10 minutes there's no cleanup there's no
mess you're done and uh and you only
have to do that once or twice a day
again because you're not that hungry
you're eating the food that is
um you know providing the nutrients that
your body needs how many times a day do
you eat uh most days it's one sometimes
it's two okay and uh are there certain
hours a day that you eat or certain
hours of day that you avoid eating uh
you know I don't do this intentionally
anymore
um the way my schedule works out I tend
to eat later in the day you know I'm a
skip breakfast
um you know work through the day and
then when I get kind of done and uh home
you know I'll typically eat late
afternoon to evening
um while I was trying to get healthy you
know the
um intermittent fasting is it's usually
referred to was more of an intentional
effort but you know after you do it for
a while it just becomes natural again
you know when we look back through our
uh history if you think about your
grandparents or great-grandparents they
weren't eating six times a day like we
do today they typically ate once or
twice a day you know when you look at
the sort of ranchers the farmer
lifestyle you know you'd have a big
breakfast before you head out into the
fields and then you come home and you
know you have your late afternoon or
early dinner and that's when you ate
again this whole messaging around eating
so often it all comes from the food
industry uh you know breakfast is the
most important meal of the day food
industry there's no science that shows
this the fact that you need to eat every
you know three hours every four hours to
fuel your day again this is all from the
food industry
when you really look at it you know we
don't need to eat nearly as often as we
do so there's really two things that
ultimately are causing our health
problems around food it's what we're
eating and it's how often we are eating
it
so I've heard the uh intermittent
fasting which uh um I tend to I'm not a
strict about it I'm not like religious
about it but uh I definitely try to eat
when I'm hungry and that tends to be mid
to late afternoon uh and what I notice
now is if I eat in the mornings uh I'm
like a little bit mentally groggy and
just it's like okay I actually like
better to eat then
um and the idea that I heard that made a
lot of sense was uh your body needs time
to relax right and so if you're
constantly giving it food is constantly
working and by only eating once or twice
a day and kind of eating in these
windows uh it allows your body to kind
of cleanse itself and relax and that's a
better way now I always like to flip
around the other side of the table and
say what's the argument I've heard for
eating all day long right that uh at
least seems to make common sense to the
average person which is if you want to
have a faster metabolism then eat very
small portions lots of times a day and
that will keep your metabolism going I
don't know if that's true it's not it's
not true okay so is that like a food
industry type thing of like this
obsession with uh uh putting food in
your body ends up igniting metabolism or
what is the relationship there based on
how you understand it yeah so again this
goes back to the uh whole concept around
calories and calories out so you know
one of the again theories as to why we
have gotten so obese why we you know
have these uh health problems is just
because we're taking in too much food
we're taking in more calories than we
burn and there's this other
um kind of misconception I guess that
probably goes along with it that if you
uh all of a sudden stop eating you know
uh your metabolism slows down and you're
going to burn less calories and again
neither of these have really uh uh have
any you know good scientific data behind
them
um
the problem with the calories in
calories out model is that we really
can't assess either side of that
equation very well okay so when you have
people try and guess try and track how
many calories they take in they're
widely inaccurate um you know and it
there's many different reasons you know
the amount of food you know no one's
sitting there really weighing their food
scientifically every day uh and even you
know if you look at packaged food and it
says it has this number of calories in
it again science shows that that can be
off by 20 25 30 percent even if it has
the label on it
so we have we're very bad at judging at
measuring how many calories do we take
in I never thought of the calories being
off but I've always thought that the
nutrition labels were full of [ __ ] I'm
like somebody's sitting here like what's
the difference between seven percent or
eight percent of you know uh total
carbohydrates like exactly literally
somebody is just guessing
um you know it a lot of it again is why
is the information that's on there even
on there I mean you know there could be
lots of different things that are on
food labels and you know they've picked
certain things to be on there uh but you
know if again if you're well intentioned
and you say okay I'm gonna count my
calories and you try and count your
calories you're not going to be able to
count them accurately and then you have
no idea how many calories you're burning
outside of a laboratory environment it
is actually exceedingly difficult to
accurately measure how many calories
someone Burns and we have all these sort
of equations that have been developed
over the years to try and estimate this
but again it ends up being widely in
inaccurate so what you're really saying
is in order to do calories and calories
out you would almost have to be
operating in such a perceived like
caloric deficit to ensure for the margin
of error that like you would eat a
thousand calories and burn four thousand
and then you could be like yes I'm for
sure you know burning more than I'm
eating but that's nearly impossible for
the average person right and then when
you try and do that you know you can't
sustain that over the long term I mean
the uh again the sort of starvation
reflex let's call it you know our bodies
uh aren't going to let us starve so it's
true that if you severely cut your
calories
um and you're in a severe caloric
deficit your body's then going to ramp
down your metabolism so now you're not
burning as much calories anymore
um and this is where the calorie and
calorie and out model as a basis for
weight loss really starts to break down
um because you know you can actually
flip it the other way there are foods
that are going to cause you to burn more
calories protein for instance it takes
more body it takes more energy for your
body to break down and process proteins
than the other macros so if you eat a
lot of protein your metabolism is
actually going to go up
um and so they have done studies they're
called pro protein over feeding studies
where they give people just a ton of
protein to eat and those people don't
get fat you know because their body is
going to basically you know ramp up
their metabolism uh to uh meet you know
to break down that protein so you know
calories in calories out becomes
completely useless essentially when
you're trying to get healthy when you're
trying to lose weight but yet it's the
message that continues to get pushed and
again you look at who is pushing that
it's the food industry but because if
you're the food industry
and you want to distract from the fact
that most of the food that you are
making is such poor quality and is
damaging People's Health
what you do is you say well it doesn't
matter the type of food that you're
eating it's just calories and calories
out so we can give you 500 calories of
junk food or we can give you 500
calories of nutritious whole real food
and there's no difference between those
two and this ends up you know feeding
the narrative and supporting what you as
the food industry are trying to do which
is just sell more of your food yeah I
forget
um I can't remember if it was Andrew
huberman David sinclairs it's somebody
kind of in that uh General scientific
community that looks at nutrition and
Longevity they were talking about a
study I think it was done with either
mice or rats uh where they basically in
the same amount of calories and simply
giving it to them throughout the entire
day versus packing it into kind of this
feeding window and uh the animal that
was essentially doing intermittent
fasting had you know 20 25 whatever it
was longer life span and the whole idea
going back to the uh being like
the calories were the same what you're
talking about is like well imagine if
then you swapped out like good calories
and bad calories even though the number
is the same it actually has a different
impact on uh on your body as well and so
I know that you're a heart surgeon uh
I'm gonna ask you a whole bunch of
questions at any point if you're like
hey I don't know like just tap out
um but I'm going to tell you some
questions that I've heard other people
talk about that they don't know the
answers I don't know the answers either
first being hey I grew up in a household
and uh I was a kid I just ate what my
parents told me to eat uh they didn't
know any of this stuff uh frankly they
didn't care about any of this stuff they
were worried about making money and
going to work and and uh you know trying
to live as happy of Life as we could
can I reverse the errors of 10 20 30 40
years by now starting to eat healthy how
do you look at and maybe in some of your
patients you've seen like can food have
a really negative effect and then just
simply making the changes today can that
reverse some of the damage that's been
done or is it more so just you can stop
creating more damage moving forward yeah
so the great news is that this can be
improved anytime you know there may be
damage that we're not able to undo you
know again when I look at the people who
end up on my operating table the people
who I'm doing surgery on
um you know
even if they
change what they eat at that point we're
probably not going to be able to avoid
the need for the surgery but we can
still improve them we can still improve
where they are and we can prevent more
future problems from occurring because
what I tell people now about heart
surgery what I tell the patients that I
operate on
is that the surgery that I'm doing isn't
changing what led to you needing the
surgery in the first place it's not
addressing that root cause and again
this is a problem we see over and over
in our Health Care system today we give
you the medicine we do the surgery we're
not addressing the root cause
but if you start to address that root
cause you can undo some of the damage
you can prevent more damage from
occurring and you can make your life
better you can improve your health
um you know I look at where I was
seven eight years ago before I started
this and I was pre-diabetic and I was
morbidly obese
thankfully I didn't get to the point
where I had you know heart disease but I
would have been there clearly
um you know and I have many
ever many lines of evidence that show me
that
um you know my dad had heart surgery my
grandmother died of heart disease so I
was clearly headed down that path for
those that don't understand when you say
heart disease you've mentioned a couple
times like what exactly is happening in
the heart it's not a heart attack it's
not like some of these things that
people may be more familiar with what
exactly is heart disease yeah so there
are many forms of heart disease but
again the most common form we talk about
is what we call atherosclerosis buildup
of plaque in the arteries on the heart
so we have to realize the heart is a
muscle and the heart is our most unique
muscle because it never stops working
until it does and that's a bad day
um
but
um so the heart is constantly pumping
and it obviously has a lot of demand for
oxygen nutrients needs a lot of blood
flow to support that and so when these
plaques start to build up in the
arteries of the heart and the blood flow
to the muscle now gets decreased it can
it has a lot of problems and it can take
a couple of different forms it can lead
to a heart attack it can lead to what we
call heart failure where the muscle
becomes too weak uh to keep up with the
pumping demands but most of the time
when people refer to heart disease this
is the type of heart disease that we're
talking about how much of that is uh
food
how much of that is stress and how much
of that is I'll call it vices uh drugs
alcohol you know whatever crazy things
that that they're doing and uh what made
me think of this is uh devices there's
some people who are very well known
especially on the internet uh for doing
all kinds of crazy stuff from drinking
all the time cocaine whatever and
they've had heart attacks in their 30s
and early 40s and you're like okay well
that seems to be an outlier maybe
there's some connection with the
lifestyle uh but then also you hear all
the time like oh that person had a heart
attack and they were just super stressed
out yeah and so I guess like is it all
three is it actually one of these things
but we as humans are dumb and we just
like to assign blame to a bunch of
different things like how do you as a
harsh surgeon look at it yeah so um you
it is all of those things and genetics
also get thrown in a lot
um what's the breakdown between them
I don't think we have exact numbers but
I today will tell you that food is
probably 90 of it really it's a big part
of it would you go as far as to say if
you ate healthy and did you know cocaine
and drank alcohol that like you'd be
better off than if you ate super
unhealthy and didn't do that stuff yeah
I probably wouldn't go quite that far
but I would say if you eat healthy
um and again what does healthy mean to
me it means eating whole real food uh
you're probably going to be just fine
you know when we look at the 80 20 rule
it's clearly the 80 percent and maybe
more is food you know it's always
interesting because people tend to think
of you know the genetics as a big part
of it and they say oh well my dad had
heart disease my grandfather is heart
disease you know I have heart disease it
must be genetic but the reality is that
much of that is the habits that can pass
down within the family so you know like
I said my grandmother had her heart
disease my father has heart disease
I don't have heart disease
do I have different genetics probably
not but I've changed these habits that
got passed down you know from my
grandmother to my father to me and I
clearly was on my way to developing
heart disease but I was able to change
my habits and avoid that so you know
what the message I try and get across to
people is that genetics do play some
role but they're very small it's mostly
our habits and our habits are what we
eat first and foremost and then the
other stuff you mentioned stress
certainly plays a role in it sleep plays
a role in it how much activity you get
plays a role in it and then there are
other toxins
um is the way that I like to think about
it besides the food that we are eating
um and these can be things like drugs uh
this can be some of the pollution you
know some of the things in our
environment uh that also clearly
contribute to heart disease but
the major cause of the heart disease
epidemic that we are seeing today that
we have been seeing for the past 70
years in this country is coming from the
food that we are eating when we see the
food pyramid when we hear the food
industry when we are teaching our kids
in schools uh what to eat and what not
to eat if you eat too much red meat you
will get heart disease uh you are a
heart surgeon and you're saying the
exact opposite yep uh and the science
says the exact option okay what's the
disagreement here between uh too much
red meat equals heart disease whereas
you're saying like no actually too much
of the other [ __ ] is causing the
heart disease and like you should
actually be eating more of this kind of
nutrient dense uh meat yeah so you know
this starts to get into uh different
types of scientific studies and without
getting too deep in the weeds uh you
know one of the major types of
scientific studies that are used when it
comes to nutrition is what we call
epidemiology okay so you track how
people eat and a lot of this is
self-reported and it's inaccurate but if
putting that aside for a moment
um we track what people eat
and then we try and correlate to their
health outcomes but the problem is you
know when you ask someone you know how
much meat you eat and they give you an
answer
a lot of that you know we don't eat meat
in isolation most of us are not eating
only red meat although me and a lot of
my friends now are eating mostly only
red meat but when someone says they ate
the hamburger what does that mean well
it means they had the meat that made up
the hamburger but most of the time it
also means they had the bun they had the
ketchup they had the toppings they had
the french fries that they had with
their hamburger and they drank the coke
you know with their hamburger as well so
you look at all that and you put it
together and you start to analyze it and
you say oh look they ate more red meat
they got more heart disease it must be
the meat that's causing it but again
maybe it was the coke maybe it was the
French fries maybe it's the bun and you
know when you really isolate out red
meat
um you cannot find a relationship with
heart disease or cancer by the way which
is another one that gets put forward or
any of these ill health effects
um
and
we can look at this in a number of
different ways but you know one of the
ways that I think is most relevant to
look at it is let's think evolutionarily
you know what have we been eating for
the vast majority of our existence as
human beings we've been eating meat what
haven't we been eating for the vast
majority of our existence as human
beings the processed food the fake oils
the you know the highly processed
carbohydrates
um so when we see these diseases that
all of a sudden have become a problem
again at a high level you have to sit
back and you have to think you know
what's more likely to be causing this
problem you mentioned oil uh Hot Topic
yeah in uh on the internet uh there's
the like canola oils there's the extra
virgin olive oils there's no oil there's
everything in between what are the good
ones and what are the ones that you're
like literally avoid at all costs and
and those are gonna you know essentially
just kill you yeah so again this is
where um it really starts to become
ironic because one of the things I tell
people is if it is a bottle of oil and
it has a heart healthy label on it it is
not heart healthy these are your
vegetable oils these are your canola
oils all of these highly processed seed
oils as they're called
um are not healthy again these are
things that have been introduced into
our food supply only within the past 100
to 150 years we actually have very good
scientific studies so I mentioned before
epidemiologic studies which are not very
good they can't show causation but there
are also things called Interventional
studies that can show causation and we
have a number of Interventional studies
looking at vegetable and Seed oils
that show that they shorten they have
higher mortality and they don't lower
the incidence of heart disease wow what
they are promoted to do they do not do
so again it's the same thing around you
know the meta concept eat whole real
food that's been minimally processed eat
the foods that we have been eating for
millions of years stay away from these
new foods that have been introduced so
what does that look like when it comes
to fats and oils it looks like animal
products so these are going to be your
animal fats things like Tallow and beef
these are going to be your butter you
know your cream your again animal
deprived animal
derived fats and then you want to look
for what are called fruit oils instead
of seed oils so fruit oils which are
your olive oil your coconut oil your
avocado oil they come from the actual
fruit as opposed to the seed takes a lot
less to extract them they don't get
processed and they seem to be less
damaging than the highly processed and
that's the problem with the seed oil is
not so much where it came from as much
as the process to actually extract it is
a heavy processing and therefore
whatever is injected and treated and all
of that getting into your body is
essentially just toxins to the body and
causing a lot of the issues yeah so it's
um it's the industrial process that goes
into extracting it and whatever that
introduces into it and it's also how the
ratios of the types of fats that are
then Changed by that processing so you
know we have
um basically you know when we look at
fats in our uh diet
they are broken into broad categories
saturated fat
and unsaturated fats and the unsaturated
fats are then further differentiated
between monounsaturated and
polyunsaturated and the more unsaturated
of fat becomes the more unstable it
becomes so it's prone to being damaged
oxidized specifically and these damaged
fats these are what ultimately leads to
the problems in our body
and so when you look at these vegetable
and Seed oils as they become more
processed they become more unsaturated
and they therefore become more prone to
damage simple sort of thought exercise
for people about this is you know that
bottle of canola oil labeled heart
healthy and you leave it out on your
counter with the cap open for like two
days what's going to happen to it it
becomes rancid it smells horrible it
changes color you know we know
instinctually stay away from it don't
eat it now go back and think about your
grandmother your great-grandmother and
they uh very likely had the bottle of uh
bacon grease that would sit out on the
counter for months at a time
and it was just fine and it would cook
with it and we would eat it and you know
no issues uh bacon grease you know lard
pig fat at that time very saturated no
problems coconut oil again a fruit oil
has basically the highest concentration
of saturated fat of almost any uh oil
that we eat you can leave it out on the
counter it's never going to go bad
essentially and this oxidation process
that happens to the vegetable oil
sitting on your countertop also happens
within our bodies and that's where the
damage really starts to occur speaking
of coconut oil one of the things
somebody sent me one time people sent me
weird food things because I know that I
like find the stuff fascinating
um was that you can actually take
coconut oil swish it around in your
mouth and then spit it out and it'll
help like clean your teeth it's like
actually one like a natural light it's
called yep oil pulling yeah and I
remember just being like who figured
that out right like so who was sitting
there like what can I put in my mouth
and see if it'll clean my teeth or not
but like there are these things that we
I think realize you're probably not
going to get that type of reaction and
process out of something that is really
bad for you right it seems pretty clear
that uh in that process it is able to uh
provide a benefit to the body uh and a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
it isn't chemicals and kind of all this
craziness that you're putting into your
body yeah exactly you know I think a lot
of this it turns out is instinctual you
know again when you go back you know
sort of through the evolutionary uh
record and you see the things that we
ate naturally uh and we've figured it
out as humans
um and again we've gotten into this
environment uh This Modern environment
where the information around food has
become so jumbled so garbled uh that now
everyone's like what do I eat it's like
we never really had a problem figuring
out what to eat in the past it's only
now that we do and you know I do think
that that is sort of intentional on many
levels uh because again if you're a food
company
and you're trying to sell this processed
food that's highly profitable but
clearly not good for our health you just
try and confuse everyone as much as
possible and they sort of throw their
hands up and they said okay I guess I'll
just eat whatever is convenient and
that's what's convenient and you have
success so you know when I'm working
with people now and I'm trying to get
them to understand how to be healthy one
of the first steps is that
intentionality about what you're eating
instead of just grabbing whatever is
most convenient
think about you know is this food
supporting my health or not uh and if we
just ask that question more I think we
would end up in a better place so dinner
lunch if you want to eat breakfast
whatever uh nutritionally dense food
tends to be meat uh we've talked a lot
about red meat what about like things
like chicken or other types of meat that
maybe aren't just steak or hamburgers or
something like that yeah so you know one
of the other issues we get into is you
know when you start to think about the
types of meat that you're going to eat
you have to start thinking about what
that animal was fed uh and I know you
know Texas slim uh certainly got into
this conversation with you uh but you
know uh ruminant animals so these are
animals that have multiple stomachs uh
these are you know beef is the most
common thing but uh you know many of the
uh red meats that we eat uh these are
all ruminant animals and one of the
magic things that ruminant animals can
do is that they can
process
these grains process what they're eating
and minimize the damage from it so they
turn a lot of the unsaturated fats that
they are fed back into saturated fat
humans can't do that non-ruminant
animals can't do that so chickens pigs
these are not ruminant animals and so
the problem with pork the problem with
chicken oftentimes these days is that if
those animals are fed very lousy diets
which they oftentimes are it's going to
have more effects in their meat so
that's why red meat is probably the
healthiest thing to eat now
is chicken better than the box of Oreos
clearly it is uh so again I tell people
at a high level you know eat real food
make that you know kind of the the first
rule
um 80 20 principle eat real food first
and then if you want to really get into
the weeds
um yeah most red meat is going to be
healthier than most non-red meat
um you know sourcing your food well uh
connecting with a local rancher in an
Ideal World and knowing what that food
that you're eating what it was eating
um is going to be uh more beneficial so
doing this at home pretty
self-explanatory go get the meat cook it
don't put crazy [ __ ] on it whatever when
you go to a restaurant there's a little
bit of a black box like you order
something on the menu it comes out it
looks good you don't really know what
happened back there is there anything
that you do when you go to a restaurant
to ensure that you're at least
increasing the probability that you're
eating healthy even if you're just
ordering a steak
um you know a lot of it just starts with
just eating the steak you know because I
can tell yeah you know is there a chance
that they threw some veg vegetable oil
on the grill with it yeah there's a
chance of that that's probably going to
have minimal effect but if I'm just
eating the steak I know I'm eating the
steak if you're eating things that are
you know have a lot of sauces in them
you don't know what's in the sauce
um uh you know obviously uh the side
dishes things like that you can you know
it can lead to more problems so I try
and keep it pretty simple when I go out
to eat you know most of the time when I
go out to eat it's going to be a steak
it's going to be a burger without the
bun without the toppings it's going to
be a piece of fish or something like
that that I can have at least a pretty
good idea of what uh went into that 80
20. 80 20 rule again
um but you know again on the big picture
the less you eat out probably the
healthier you're going to be you know if
we got better connected with our food if
we prepare our food if we know what goes
into it that's going to lead us to a
better a place than if we're Outsourcing
that to someone else yeah
airports I've seen you tweet about this
before there's no good food in an
airport this is coming from somebody in
2019 took 120 flights yep I lived in
airports I ate in airports every single
day was horrendous uh I got to the point
where I would like uh go and get like a
cliff bar and I was like well I guess
this is maybe sort of possibly the most
healthy thing I could get here
um now I'm a little bit more intentional
if I'm ever in an airport in terms of
going and sitting at the restaurant and
have enough time and all that are there
any tips or tricks when people are in
airports or traveling a lot that they
should kind of adhere to maybe it's just
not eat at the airport I don't know yeah
well so yeah travel becomes a great uh
time to uh fast uh to do the
intermittent fasting have you ever had
Auntie Anne's though you smell it from
all the way down the terminal you're
like I gotta go stop again they're
manipulating you um but yeah I travel a
lot too you know so uh my heart surgery
work these days is all travel you know
I'm on airplanes uh you know three weeks
a month I'm flying back and forth for
the most most part so I travel a lot so
fasting is is probably my best rule but
really you know go to any of the burger
places and order a couple of burger
patties without the bun without the
toppings you'll be all right is it the
highest quality meat no it's not but
again it's still going to be better than
the Alternatives or if you have the time
to sit down at the restaurant and order
the steak or you know some grilled
shrimp or a grilled piece of fish
something simple like that those are my
go-to's
um and then you know what can you bring
with you you know things like uh a beef
jerky you know that's made without you
know too much sugar uh Bill Tong which
is a South African uh type of beef jerky
essentially that's cleaner uh great
thing to you know throw in your bag some
nuts uh you know things like this uh
that you can take with you or another uh
great but it it comes again back to that
intentionality back to that sort of
thing thinking about it planning about
it a little bit and you know can you
before you get to the airport can you do
after you get to you know after you get
to wherever you're going uh these are uh
some of the things I think about but it
is interesting you know the airport as a
sort of microcosm of our environment uh
and then being on the airplane and
you're just like you know do you see the
article recently that says when you're
in the air your uh taste buds they
change and therefore part of the
airplane menu uh they try to create a
menu that when you're on the airplane in
the air it will actually be things that
you think taste well so that I think
they said um tomato juice I think like a
lot of people like I think it was tomato
juice uh for whatever reason you it uh
the amount that is ordered on the
airplane is way outpacing in our normal
restaurant or anything and it has
something to do with the changes
physiologically while uh while you're in
the air I haven't seen that article but
an interesting to think about and so
like do you eat on the air airplane or
are you just like I'm staying away from
anything that they possibly could give
me while uh 30 000 feet in the air yeah
it's pretty rare that I'm gonna be
eating on an airplane you know a pretty
long you know overseas trip I might uh
you know try and uh pick out you know
pick away you know they bring you the
whole plate and uh you know and also you
know I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
I'm perfect I'm not going to tell you
it's that you know I never eat processed
food uh I'm human uh but again 80 20
Rule and think about where you are and
what your goals are this is another key
concept around this you know if you are
very unhealthy
which unfortunately most of us are but
if you're very unhealthy and you're
trying to get healthy you know that's
going to look different than if you're
healthy and you're active
um you know then yeah you do have some
tolerance for some of this stuff you
know again most of this stuff isn't
acutely poisonous to us it's not going
to kill you right away and in small
amounts every once in a while it's
probably going to be fine uh so you know
once or twice a month when I'm out with
my family and I'm out with my kids and
yeah I have dessert at the restaurant
um you know and uh but canceled it's not
every night you know and uh again I'm I
you know the other 95 percent of the
time uh I am eating just whole real food
and so uh and I've gotten healthy you
know again a lot different than you know
eight years ago when I was morbidly
obese and I was pre-diabetic uh so you
have to you know you take all of that
into account you mentioned sleep earlier
and it's something that over the last
two years I've gotten obsessive about it
I used to
six hours maybe
um
and I just thought that's how like
everyone lived right was you're kind of
let me get some coffee and then move
through it now I sleep eight hours
almost religiously every single night
sometimes a little bit more
um
and if I ever have to sleep six because
I misjudged time or I got to get up
early to do something whatever
um
I feel horrible like I'm like I cannot
believe that I live life this way and
the number one thing that I notice
horrible uh emotional regulation right
just I'm irritable I'm like all the
things that people associate with uh
lack of sleep second thing is I eat
horribly yeah I eat different types of
food and I eat way more uh as well how
what's the science behind that is or is
that just me like in my own head and I'm
like oh I want some six hours so let me
go eat like a pig and blame it on the
sleep this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine I sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself and eat sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally change my
life and I begged the founders to let me
invest in the company eightsleep.com pom
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep no we do
have uh some pretty good science you
know that reinforces that so sleep is
essential to our health
um you know what I tell people is again
two things to consider in terms of your
sleep similar to food it's the amount
that you're sleeping but it's also the
Quality quality of your sleep uh so you
know six hours of good high quality
sleep can oftentimes be better than
eight hours of poor quality sleep uh so
you know this is where you want to start
paying attention to the things that are
affecting the quality of your sleep
um the foods that we eat affects the
quality of our sleep you know that
relationship between food and sleep
works both ways because when we eat
lousy food we sleep worse and when we
sleep worse we get hungrier we get more
iterable we want to eat more of the
lousy food that you know kind of makes
us
um maybe feel a little better in the
short term
um but uh clear relationship there so
you know again
what are the high level Concepts what
you eat is most important but then the
other things that come into play sleep
is probably the next biggest one I I'm
an investor in a company uh eight sleep
they've had the thermoregulated mattress
and uh
um although I love the team I love the
product all the stuff one of the most
valuable pieces of the product to me is
I get a notification every day and it's
almost like a lottery right like a
notification will say uh uh have less
energy today don't be surprised like
your heart rate was six percent higher
last night than average or like this
morning your heart rate uh was 10
percent lower than on average like
that's why you have so much energy
and I like ask myself like do I feel
like I have more or less energy and
maybe it's 80 90 of the time I actually
do feel like there's some variability to
it and of course the uh implicit thing
is that it's the product itself right
and yeah if I sleep with the dice cold
so like that should be helping me uh but
how much of that actual like heart
performance in your sleep has an impact
on some of this stuff like if you can
drive that resting heart rate while
you're sleeping down uh whether it's
through a product I eat sleep it's
exercise food whatever like is that
actually really really important
um yeah so uh specifically uh what we're
talking about there is what's called
heart rate variability HRV
um and it does seem to have a impact on
uh recovery and on performance
um you know I do always question you
know how much of this is uh you know
sort of the placebo effect the
psychologic effect that you see that
number and you're like oh today's going
to be a great day or you see that number
and you're like today it's not going to
be such a great day
um but you know we do see Coraline it so
uh for a lot of people one of the things
um you know that I that they'll notice
around HRV and sleep is if you you know
don't drink alcohol for a period of time
your HRV tends to get better or at least
you don't drink it too close to going to
sleep your HRV is going to get better
um you know uh people uh who you know
I'll notice in myself you know that once
or twice a month that I do have the
dessert when we're out to dinner and
then I go home and I'm like I didn't
sleep so good that night you know uh and
HRV is one of the ways to uh to measure
that I'm going to tell you a crazy story
this is not an experience I had but I
have a friend who will go unnamed uh was
in Las Vegas
um and Dave's at the club and according
to the way he told me the stories he saw
Tiger Woods at the club and he was
having a freaking blast and he was going
back to his hotel room and he just
happened to go by the gym right and he
saw Tiger Woods running on the treadmill
at like 3 30 4 o'clock in the morning
and so he was like whatever and this
guy's in the Sports World right and so
he he goes into the gym and he's
basically like uh Hey man like what are
you doing I saw you drinking it's four
o'clock in the morning and uh the way he
tells the story is that tiger basically
was like if you sweat it out before you
go to sleep it doesn't count
what possible science is there behind uh
you mentioned not drinking right before
you go to sleep uh is there anything
around uh the effect on your heart or on
your sleep of like actually sweating out
alcohol before uh you go to bed you know
there probably is something to
processing the alcohols okay in some way
uh so you know alcohol is a toxin to our
bodies it's interesting you know uh when
we think about uh you know where we get
energy from
um you know everyone thinks about
carbohydrates and they think about
dietary fat
um and you know what they don't
oftentimes account for is you know
alcohol is uh another energy source for
our body uh but alcohol is toxic to our
bodies so if there's alcohol in the
system the body's going to do everything
it can to get rid of that alcohol first
and foremost uh and it's going to stop
processing the things down the line so
you know the sugar that so many of us
take with our alcohol you know it
basically ends up hanging out in our
bodies longer while our bodies trying to
get rid of that alcohol so exercise uh
sweating uh these are other ways of you
know processing this of getting rid of
it so there probably is something to
that
um you know I'm assuming this was Tiger
in his younger days and and he probably
was able to handle it anyway uh being in
such great shape uh but yeah you know if
you can do something to uh get rid of
that alcohol whether it's exercise or go
sit in the sauna or something like that
there probably is some validity to that
now again does that mean that you should
drink more alcohol because oh you can
just go sit in the sauna doesn't quite
work that way yeah so as a heart surgeon
one of the things I I've always been
fascinated by especially specifically
around the heart and I think like
lifestyle is uh when I was in college
um there was uh an absolute uh explosion
of energy drinks and then alcoholic
energy drinks and I remember kind of
watching these you know become popular
and at some point some of them were
forced to actually change the formula
because it seemed like the amount of
energy during was actually masking how
much alcohol was being delivered and
kids were dying and it got pretty
gruesome uh
how much impact does I guess caffeine
these energy drinks Etc have on the
heart and like how bad are they for you
right somebody goes and grabs a monster
or a Red Bull and they drink one a week
versus if you're drinking one a day like
is that any different than drinking
coffee or how do you think about that
yeah I do think there are some uh
uniquely
um you know damaging effects from uh
these products and and you know it's
probably the concentrated caffeine with
the sugar that is in most of these
energy drinks as well uh so you know
coffee is one of these interesting
um uh things that you know the science
is always flipping on you know coffee is
good for you coffee's bad for you uh
coffee and eggs I think are the two most
common things that you know you get
every week There's a new study coming
out
in the end
um I don't think that there's anything
too damaging about drinking coffee
um I don't think it's the caffeine
itself that's necessarily a problem uh
but when you start to combine caffeine
sugar
um in these high amounts in these
concentrated amounts not great for you
um you know so we talk about processed
food we also have to think about
processed drink we have to think about
you know
um one of the other big rules you know
that I and many others give for people
who are trying to improve their health
is don't drink calories there's really
no need to drink calories and there's
you know the the forms that the calories
we can drink come in are usually going
to be from sugar they're going to be
from processed food so you know probably
uh something that we should avoid uh for
the most part is uh drinking calories uh
but yeah there clearly was
um an association between these energy
drinks uh and uh you know negative uh
effects on the heart uh and they're not
not something that I recommend yeah what
about protein shakes we mentioned
earlier high protein diet obviously
getting used to metabolism and kind of
all these things but it's a synthetic
form right it's a powder that ends up
getting kind of add water and supposed
to deliver all this protein yep it I'm
assuming it's not as good as steak but
is it like the next best thing or should
people avoid these yeah you know I think
again uh they probably
if they're a limited part they shouldn't
be your primary source of protein
ultimately uh and ultimately you're
always going to be better getting it as
whole real food but you know real life
happens and convenience and uh you know
sometimes it's just not feasible to get
enough protein or you know to have it in
forms that are available to you uh so I
tell people if you're going to use
protein shakes you know try and make
sure they are as clean as possible I
recommend animal derived proteins uh I
think are better absorbed provide a
better amino acid profile than the plant
proteins uh so you know I try and look
for a nice clean whey protein shake
um and again keep it as simple as
possible you know if you're taking that
protein powder one of the big mistakes I
see this oftentimes will be at the gym
people go and they do their workout and
then they go to the Smoothie Bar
and you're like oh well there's protein
powder in my smoothie so it must be
healthy but meanwhile it's sugar and you
know all this other processed stuff
that's going into that smoothie
um and so you know is the protein powder
itself damaging probably not uh but all
the other stuff you've now put into that
smoothie
um is you know going to be undoing a lot
of the uh you know benefits that you've
gotten from the time at the gym it's
it's an area that I tell people you
should be cautious about and again be
intentional find the best you know
cleanest simplest protein powder you can
get and then you know make the Smoothie
yourself with you know like my go-to is
going to be whole milk a little bit of
protein powder uh and then uh you know
that's really all you need uh and that
protein shake is going to be better than
the pre-packaged pre-made protein shake
that has like 12 different ingredients
in it uh that you can't pronounce so you
mentioned milk uh growing up I'm pretty
sure we just drank two percent milk on
that was just what we got uh uh was in
the refrigerator uh you kind of get used
to it installed whole milk or something
else tastes like a little off right
um whole milk obviously I think has uh
had a Resurgence maybe like people are
like more excited about it then there's
raw milk which is like a whole nother
thing how do you look at these milks and
like what's good for you what's not good
for you
if you're just drinking milk is that
like 80 20 and hey milk is better than
no milk or what do you think yeah so
um you know so whole milk is my typical
recommendation
um anything that's other than whole milk
again is going to be more processed so
two percent milk skim milk whatever
they've done they've taken the fat out
and they've replaced it with sugar
carbohydrates uh so uh if you're gonna
drink milk I recommend whole milk the
raw milk thing
um you know may have some validity to it
so the
um pasteurization process which again
was originally promoted for food safety
reasons
um we see that it damages the proteins
in that milk it changes them so our
bodies can't process them as well there
is a lot of debate about you know
whether we should be drinking milk at
all you know you look at all other
mammals and once they are weaned one
there and you know out of childhood they
basically stop drinking milk
is milk damaging to us hard to say uh
you know we get into all the issues with
lactose intolerance but again a lot of
that comes from the processing of the
milk
um the
um
the gut damage
um you know the intestinal damage that
so many of us have because of the food
that we have been eating that then allow
these milk proteins to get across the
barrier in our gut that they don't
normally get across and so we say we're
intolerant to the milk but it turns out
that we just have gut damage from the
lousy food that we're eating so I have
worked with a number of people who you
know I'm lactose intolerant they tell me
and you know we go through all the thing
we get their diet cleaned up and their
gut heals and their overall health
improves and now they can start drinking
milk again and they don't have the
problems with it uh so you know it
oftentimes becomes hard to separate out
uh you know is it the milk itself or is
it other things you know that have
damaged to our health that we are now no
longer able to tolerate this
um this leads to like the the kombucha
and like oh I'm mispronounced every
single word because it's like kind of
woo-woo science to me but at least leads
to gut health and like oh we can do all
this other stuff yeah which kind of
feels like maybe you're hinting at that
like what you're eating ruins something
in your gut and now you're going to take
something else to try to cure what is
could just be cured by eating healthy
food exactly yeah that's you know gut
health is probably a whole nother topic
that we can spend another three hours on
but yeah a lot of that comes down to
exactly that you know why are our guts
unhealthy it's because of the food that
we are eating and when you get back to
eating whole real food and the gut heals
and all of a sudden a lot of these gut
problems get better you know again I've
now worked with a number of people
um and uh you know I've had uh you know
contact with a lot more people and they
had all of these gut problems um
irritable bowel disease uh you know that
got fixed when they change the food that
they are eat and all the medications
that they were given and a lot of these
people end up unfortunately needing
surgery and things like that and most of
it can be tracked down tracked back to
the food that they ate one of your most
interesting ideas uh which I know
nothing about is the connection between
metabolic health and mental health and
when I saw you Tweeting about this I was
like man I don't think I've really heard
that many people talk about that because
usually the mental health thing is like
uh uh I call it the thoughts and prayer
strategy like oh my word should help you
or there is a strategy around uh let's
just give you like pharmaceutical
medicine
explain more as to the connection
between metabolic health and mental
health and like why you think that if
you fix your metabolic Health that may
actually help on some of this other
stuff yeah and this is something that
has been most fascinating to me as well
because you know as a heart surgeon I
didn't think a lot about mental health
um and then as you get into this
metabolic Health thing and uh for
instance uh Dr Christopher Palmer he's a
psychiatrist
who has now published extensively on
this has a upcoming book
um and uh you know is probably one of
the leaders in this area
and he has shown clear relationships
between our metabolic health and our
mental health and that a lot of our
mental health issues
probably stems from inflammation in the
brain and you know just like we get the
inflammation in our gut from eating
these uh processed foods these unhealthy
Foods we get inflammation in our brain
and he has extensive experience with
pretty Advanced mental health disorders
things like schizophrenia
that he routinely now and he's been
doing this for 20 years he routinely
sees improvements in these serious
mental health conditions just by
changing the food that people are eating
wow yeah mind-blowing stuff and not even
necessarily exercise I'm sure exercise
gets laid in as well but just food alone
exactly improve the metabolic Health
which then could have an impact on the
mental health yep just changing the food
that we eat wow and there are many
different reasons that that can be true
that may be true you know at uh the
physiologic level you know inflammation
in the brain
um the fuel that your brain is running
on the fuel that your body is running on
one of the other major
sort of shifts that we see on a
metabolic level when we stop eating
processed food when we eat less
carbohydrates is our bodies start
relying more on fat for energy
ketogenesis the ketogenic diet that
we've all heard so much about what that
means at a physiologic level is that the
primary fuel source that our body is
using shifts from sugars to fats
essentially
and this has a lot of unique effects uh
and it turns out that two of the organs
that it probably has the most effect on
are our brains and our heart
um so uh when you shift your body
towards the ketogenic metabolism in the
brain and the Brain starts using more
ketones for energy than sugar for energy
a lot of good things happen and again
this is probably our Baseline this is
how we were meant to function and
um getting back to that can fix a lot of
these mental health problems that we see
do you have patients like measure are
they in ketosis or not or uh anything
like like I I guess like how serious or
obsessed do you want them to be about
actually getting to like that ketosis
you know kind of uh environment versus
hey just do the 80 20 and like do enough
to kind of be headed in that direction
yeah so again it depends on you know
where you're coming from and what your
goals are uh there are certain
conditions
that you do need to maintain pretty
strict ketosis and so I will have people
measure
um
if it's just a general Health thing
probably not as necessary
um and it's also you know as you get
used to it you know the information
maybe doesn't become as useful anymore
when you're first trying to do these
things getting that feedback are you in
ketosis can be useful uh and so
sometimes I will have people measure it
but oftentimes I don't uh
when you start to look at some of these
feedback tools that we can get some of
these things that we can measure
probably the most useful thing and again
Hot Topic that many people are hearing
about continuous glucose monitoring and
we see uh you know many people who wear
continuous glucose monitors uh that is
actually something that I think can be
very useful and again it's going to
depend on where you're starting from
what you're trying to achieve you know
do you need it all the time for most
people probably not but at the beginning
of your journey I find it to be very
useful with patients because you know
when we get back to again the foods that
we're eating
and we oftentimes don't have something
that we can immediately get that
feedback you know you eat the food you
might not feel bad right away it's only
over many months and years that these
things start to build up uh but our
blood sugar level is something that we
can measure and we now have very good
tools continuous glucose monitors that
we can see it immediately and uh you
know if you eat the food and your blood
sugar is shooting up uh that is a
problem and it's a problem maybe with
your underlying state of health and it
also may be a problem with the food so
continuous glucose monitors I recommend
them often I use them often with my
patients
Ketone measurements again can be useful
we don't have a continuous Ketone uh
monitor would probably be useful uh
continuous insulin monitoring would
probably be one of the most useful
things we can find figure out but we
don't have it available so but
intermittent currently measuring insulin
is another thing that I do with my
patients as well I've got a friend uh
Jeff Wu who started company hvmn and
they recently were able to get their
hands on some IP from uh DARPA and the
US government uh about 15 20 years ago
what they saw was they ran some tests on
if we gave people ketones could we get
them to a state of ketosis on a faster
basis and the idea was basically can we
take our war Fighters that are out on
the battlefield give them a drink
essentially and if that works then like
this would be amazing uh he has been
able to commercialize it I think it's
called Ketone IQ uh he's given to me
I've used it something's going on right
when I drink it something happens yeah
I'm not a scientist but like as I told
him we recorded conversation I think I'm
high right like like you just have this
like mental Clarity or whatever
how do you think about the potential for
external things whether they're pills
drinks you know whatever it is uh to
help the patient versus you're just
focused on like this is all about the
food and if you get the food right then
like you might not even need some of
this other stuff yeah so uh you know my
default is you know can we do this sort
of I guess you would say naturally you
know yeah can we achieve this just by
you know the food that we're eating
avoiding certain toxins
um and if we can't you know then things
like supplements
um may become useful uh and there are a
number of reasons that that might occur
and there are also uh certain conditions
um you know that maybe damage has been
done that's you know already advanced
and we can't undo it all by changing
what we eat and supplements you know
again uh may become useful so you know
when you look at things like ketone own
supplements
of any sort probably the two areas where
we have the most data showing your
usefulness
Alzheimer's disease and again the unique
effects of ketones on the brain and
heart failure the unique effects of
ketones on the heart so there have been
some early scientific studies some
animal data that in these two conditions
in particular Ketone supplementation
might be useful now again if we could
accomplish
high levels of ketosis therapeutic
therapeutic ketosis just by changing the
food that we eat probably better and in
most cases we can but in other
situations you know I do see some
usefulness for it it's crazy how
important that uh kind of end state of
ketosis ends up being for the for the
body
um another topic I thought would be
interesting to talk uh through is I'm in
my mid-30s uh I have always been uh
interested in physical health or I
played sports did all this stuff but
never from a pure data science
standpoint or or like as I would
consider like a nerd you know going in
and trying to accomplish this
historically have been uh may I go to
the doctor if something's wrong but like
you know what's the point
um and uh when I got an Apple watch all
of a sudden oh how many steps they got
the Rings like they got all these little
kind of data points like that's
interesting but didn't really change my
behavior that much and then I started to
get more serious about it I started
worrying about sleep and here we go the
next like big leap I think for me who I
would put myself in the category of I'm
not the the pure novice but I'm still
kind of amateur in terms of getting
serious about your health and
understanding some of this stuff
is blood work and it feels like the
blood work I got some friends who are
real serious and not gonna get my blood
work done every you know three months
some people get every week or whatever
it is and they're obsessed about it when
you first deal with a a a client or a
patient what do you have them go get to
just establish the Baseline like is it
hey go get this crazy study done that
you know takes forever or is it like no
I'm really just looking for like one or
two data points and that tells me you
know 80 what I need to know how do you
look at blood work and kind of a
starting point or a baseline yeah so um
I would say my typical blood work
recommendations are more towards the
basic side
um there are some Advanced things that
I'll typically look at with people uh
but really you know just starting
Baseline if you want to know you know
are you in good metabolic Health uh the
key blood test to look at
um first of all you want to uh look at
your blood sugar level and better than
just looking at a spot blood sugar your
level is what's called a hemoglobin A1c
and this is a reflection of your average
blood sugar over the past three months
essentially so it's a little bit better
than just looking at a spot you know one
spot in time
the cholesterol panel it turns out is
important to look at but not how most
doctors look at it when you get your
cholesterol panel done your most
Physicians look at one number on that
panel the LDL cholesterol the so-called
bad cholesterol and they're going to
tell you this is the most important
number when it comes to your health and
what I'm going to tell you is it's not
and again a whole other topic uh that we
can get into but when I look at a
cholesterol panel I look at two other
measurements on there
the HDL cholesterol the good cholesterol
level as it's called and the
triglycerides uh and you can look at the
ratio between those two so the
triglycerides divided by the HDL and
that's going to give you an indicator of
your metabolic Health specifically it's
going to give you an indicator of is
your body sensitive to insulin so
insulin resistance when your body
becomes insensitive to the effects of
insulin is the primary physiologic
derangement that occurs with poor
metabolic health
[Music]
um and that leads us to another very
important measurement for basic blood
work which is check your insulin level
and again most doctors don't do this so
I advise everyone get your fasting
insulin level so again you should be
about 8 to 12 hours fasted when you do
this and see what your insulin level is
and you wake up in the morning then you
can go ahead and just take it and that
should be good enough correct yeah uh so
uh that's another important thing
um and honestly if you just check those
couple of things you're going to get a
pretty good sense of where you are in
your health now I end up doing a lot you
know probably some more advanced things
I end up uh you know again getting back
to the cholesterol question you can get
into the advanced lipid panel where we
look at the sizes of your cholesterol
particles uh those are also things that
are important but you really don't have
to be doing these extensive blood panels
for most people now again if you have
specific problems that you're trying to
address they may become useful
another very important test this gets
outside of the blood work but probably
um when people come to me specifically
around heart health and they say what
tests should I get to know if my heart
is healthy
what I think is probably the best test
to get in one of the most underutilized
tests today is what's called a coronary
artery calcium scan a CAC scan
so this is a simple easy to do CAT scan
the test literally takes five minutes to
do they don't have to put an IV in you
it's a low dose of radiation it's about
the same radiation you get from having a
chest x-ray and it's typically pretty
inexpensive you can get it done for
somewhere between 100 and 200 insurance
won't cover it in many cases we can get
into that whole discussion but this will
actually show you whether or not you're
developing plaque specifically calcified
plaques in the arteries of your heart
and this will show you again are you
developing heart disease way before it
becomes you know symptomatic to the
point that you're having chest pains uh
which is for older people normally
um you know I typically will advise
people in their 30s and 40s to get a
baseline test because if you're already
showing plaque and you're in your 30s
that's a very bad sign now if you don't
have plaque in your in your 30s what I
tell people is you know it's not that
much of a guarantee
um as opposed to if you're in your 70s
and you have zero plaque you have a zero
CAC score it's a pretty much guarantee
that you're not going to die of heart
disease
um so uh I don't think it needs to be
um reserved only for older people I
usually tell people like I said get a
baseline test in your 30s or 40s
especially if you know you have reason
to think you're at risk for heart
disease if you're diabetic if you're
insulin resistant if you're overweight
then get the scan let's find out where
you're starting from do you have heart
disease already and then can we stop the
progression of that heart disease and
the answer in most cases is yes we can
with all the things that we've been
talking about today so you get these
tests done and let's say that you come
back uh and you're not diabetic you're
not insulin resistant but uh you're not
zero whether it's the plaque or or uh
some of the metrics are like ah yep you
know you're higher than we'd like you to
be yeah food seems to be the number one
place hey if we correct the diet what
about exercise like are there certain
types of exercises that go for a long
run lift heavy weights go for a walk
like how do you think about the exercise
component what's probably best for the
heart yeah so um the two concepts I try
and get people to understand around
exercise number one is be more active uh
so that doesn't mean you need to go to
the gym for an hour a day it just means
be more active uh you know walk around
more during the day
take that break take that 10 minute
break you know if you're sitting at your
desk all day take a 10 minute break
every hour and get up and do a few laps
around the building take the stairs
instead of the escalator or the elevator
when you can you know Park further away
or walk the extra block uh wherever
you're going uh use stand-up desks
instead of sitting all day simple things
like this are probably going to be more
effective than if you go to the gym for
the hour a day you run on the treadmill
and then you just sit around the rest of
the day when it comes to exercise
your priority I believe should be
building and maintaining muscle
again we have very good scientific data
showing that the better you're able to
maintain muscle as you get older not
only the longer you live but the better
quality of life that you're going to
have so build and maintain muscle the
other the you know the other benefit of
muscle is it really gives you more
leeway in terms of metabolic Health the
more muscle we have the more
metabolically healthy we are going to be
uh so you know if you're going to the
gym
prioritize building muscle and then just
try and get more activity throughout
your day yeah the the building muscle I
think is um uh such an easy one uh to
conceptualize right or to understand the
concept
um doing it I find a lot of people who
uh they're like ah what do you mean
um I don't want to be a bodybuilder
right and it always cracks me up because
the people usually say that I just yeah
I don't think you're gonna have to do
the window no one becomes a bodybuilder
by accident I don't think you're the
person who's likely to have that problem
um but it also does get at the this very
uh interesting idea which is
um we live these sedentary lives and uh
your idea of like be more active I think
is kind of one key piece but building
muscle doesn't have to go you know go
bench press go do some of this stuff
like it can literally just be if you've
never exercised before and you start to
exercise you will build muscles uh or
you will realize things uh are tough
that you didn't otherwise realize and
we're in the military uh there would
always be the person being you know a
smart ass or whatever especially like
basic training and they used to take a
piece of paper and they'd say oh yeah
you're a tough guy okay and they would
hand them the piece of paper and they'd
have them hold the with two fingers on
either side they'd hold the paper out in
front of them they leave them for like
30 45 minutes an hour or whatever and
they come back out of the person's like
shaking right they can't hold the paper
they go out there so stuff guy can't
hold this paper up right and so it's
like those types of things they build
muscle a very different way but like
something as simple as like holding a
piece of paper up in front of you for an
hour can be incredibly difficult and
physically challenging activity and
other people who could bench press the
world can't do that and it's kind of a
crazy you know dichotomy yeah no and and
that's exactly it when it comes to you
know building muscle you have to think
about resistance you know exercise
resistant activities and walking is a
resistance activity you know and like
you said if you just do more walking
you're going to build muscle you know
body weight exercises can be very
effective so you know if someone's
asking me where to start I'll tell them
start by doing some push-ups some
pull-ups and some squats if you do those
three things and you do it you know you
don't have to do it for a long time you
know 15 minutes a day four days a week
can be more than enough uh and you know
there are a number of ways to do this
you know I personally again we get back
to travel a lot and okay so you can't
get to the gym you know I use uh the X3
system which I'm sure many people have
heard of but it's basically just a
resistance band and a bar and a plate
and you know you can do a 15 minute
workout and I do it you know four times
a week there are two sets of exercises
there's your pushing your polls and you
do it you know each one of them twice a
week and that's that's enough uh you
know there are other people uh that I
talk that I talk with uh you know
there's a uh Dr Ben bachiccio
um who his um you know he has a very
simple you know band and body weight uh
program uh uh you know Jerry uh texera
is another one again
simple body weight things can be very
effective you don't have to spend all
your life at the gym and then as you
alluded to you know no one becomes a
bodybuilder by accident but really you
know what does it take to build muscle
it takes eating protein and it takes
doing some resistance exercise and so if
we just start shifting that direction
eat more protein do more resistance
exercise you're going to end up in a
better place than where you started it's
um it's simple hard execution that's
exactly it how can people interact with
you like like you you have obviously uh
the heart surgery you know kind of
component of your life uh hopefully
nobody's interacting yes no one wants to
intentionally interact with me there but
you do a lot of other things that I
think kind of prevent people from
getting to that point we'll explain a
little bit more about kind of some stuff
you're doing yeah so my goal
um you know uh for the past few years
and moving forward is to keep as many
people off of my Opera rating table as
possible so you know along those lines
I've tried and figured you know trying
to figure out how best to do that for as
many people as possible so first way I
tell people best way to interact with me
is my book it's called stay off my
operating table
and that's exactly what I want you to do
widely available all the usual places
um so uh you can start there
um I have a group coaching program
um that I invite people to uh you can go
to ifixsharts.com and you can find all
about the group coaching program uh you
can also find out there about some of
the courses I offer uh you know just a
lot of the educational stuff and then I
do have a private telemedicine practice
where I do work with people one-on-one I
do this all via telemedicine so I see
people from throughout the United States
that information is at
ovadiahethealth.com ovadia heart
health.com and you can find out about
becoming a member of my practice there
yeah it's um it's pretty incredible in
the digital age how you can take uh what
used to be somewhat localized knowledge
where that you could apply and now
you're able to build products that can
be consumed asynchronously uh in a group
setting or one on one and uh what
excites me about it is like for the
people with knowledge and information
that can change people's lives you can
get that word out to so many more people
I mean even the fact that you and I were
able to connect on the internet right it
is something that wasn't possible 20
years ago and now it just feels like uh
people who are looking and actually
serious about changing their life and
their health they can do that now
because the information's out there and
access to the right people yeah exactly
and you know I know how much you talk
about you know building things to change
these problems that we have you know
we're all aware of this problem I think
around our health so what can we start
building to really change that what are
some of the big ideas that are going to
lead us forward in health and so you
know that's another area that I work in
um you know these are other projects
that I think about uh for instance
um you know I'm currently uh involved in
a project that's conceptualizing you
know how can your home help you to
remain healthy you know what does a
healthy home really look like and all of
this data that we have around us around
Health you know we have our wearables we
can measure all these things about our
environment what if your home was
collecting all of that information what
if it was going to a health care team
that was proactively thinking about your
health and not about you know how do we
take care of you when you're sick but
how do we keep you from getting sick
yeah so just thinking about you know big
Concepts like this and what we can do
again just to normalize Health you know
over the past 50 years we have
normalized being unhealthy and we need
to change it we need to normalize Health
again let's make healthy great again
and let's think about you know how we
can really bring Health uh back into the
conversation yeah and where can people
follow you on Twitter uh at Twitter I'm
on iFix Hearts is my handle there pretty
good um yeah exactly I I was very lucky
so you know early days of Twitter I got
on I'm like I don't know what this
Twitter thing is but it seems to be a
good place to you know get some news uh
and uh I grabbed iFix Hearts
um as a heart surgeon and uh here I am
10 years later and it's exploded you
know for me it's now the main way you
know I probably interact with people
it's how you and I uh started uh
interacting uh and
um but grabbing iFix Hearts turned out
to be one of those pretty fortuitous uh
things all those years ago I I love it
uh it's very easy to understand what
what you do right there's no uh there's
no secret but listen I learned a ton
today I really appreciate the time and
uh uh you're a wealth of knowledge and I
think
um what what's uh so exciting and kind
of fascinating is that uh you have a
very specific view of the world but I
think that you're sympathetic headache
and understand that like humans are
humans and you can't show up and be like
upend your whole life and change
everything and you're like look if you
can you know do this one thing and and
you know oh you drink five sodas I know
you said hey drink five sodas a week
maybe drink four right and kind of just
slowly ease people in the right
direction
um which seems like you yourself did as
well uh it's a pretty powerful concept
to not only have that strong view of the
world but also understand that you know
it doesn't matter unless people actually
uh kind of internalize it and act on it
yeah thank you for that I mean you know
ultimately uh I try and get people to
understand you know I've been there I've
been through the struggle uh you know I
I have all the challenges you know I
lead the busy life and I have the work
and the family and all of that uh but it
really doesn't take a whole lot of
effort if you just understand these
simple Concepts uh and it can be a very
um easy to integrate it into your life
um that doesn't mean it's easy to do but
once you get educated once you
understand
um you know what is it that's damaging
your health
um it really is not
um
that complex as to how to undo these
things and how to make yourself healthy
again how to take back your health
that is uh uh gonna help somebody out
there which which I appreciate you your
time your effort and uh we'll be
cheering for you and hopefully we'll do
this again in the future as you continue
to make progress sounds good thanks
Anthony